something to admit what when I asked you
to come to the mall so we could get food
I lied oh you know how we have that
Google thing tomorrow if we look and act
like scrubs tomorrow they're not gonna
go for it and then that's that yeah why
I mean like what you got like what's
wrong with how I look I mean like
frickin Peter Jackson can accept an
Oscar looking like a scrub so I can't
why can't I is that is that suddenly
Peter Jackson right you're you're a
director yeah sure
okay if you see talent that doesn't look
the part are you gonna cast that talent
no so think of yourself as talent here
it's not about the way that you like to
dress personally it's a way it's a way
of giving the impression to the product
that you're the right spokesperson okay
man that's a lot of pressure
yeah okay you know what this is not
normally what I do but I'll do it I'll
do it for you guys I'll whip myself into
shape
we'll be a whole new Sam this is gonna
be the transformation you're down of Sam
- cool
Sam well I mean I feel like I feel like
I know we might have to fire somebody
[Music]
we are on set of the Google Chromebook
shoot they're kind of doing a little
feature piece on corridor digital in our
process featuring the Google Chrome bus
is it is it really touch man hmm pretty
sweet in a laptop right you look like a
combo why didn't a horn ego have to get
new clothes I get how I need to improve
my passion Jake and Nico look totally
normal they didn't improve their passion
look at this black shirt blue jeans and
look at me look at your pants even more
the shoes and socks you picked out for
me literally first thing that happened
today I walked in and the stylist comes
over and looks at me and she's like I
love everything you're wearing this is
perfect and she left we're basically for
the camera showing a step-by-step
walkthrough generally how we work on
videos talking about okay there's
brainstorming this little scripting
there's some storyboarding for the shots
where we brainstorm about how we brain
some videos and we're actually
brainstorming this bunch right all right
are you ready there you go that's the
pitch
try to make me punch think we got like a
it was like at least 40 people on this
crew right now so it's pretty big deal
it feels pretty cool to be the center of
attention and not doing lists of the
work it's pretty sweet touchscreen is
the best part
well we turn make videos that are cool
and look nice all the spectacled a big
movie with the affordability of the
YouTube video yeah making a good film
takes a lot of communication if you're
going to make a work of art you want
everybody to be passionate about it easy
it's easy to come up with to come an
idea for a video like the CD but to
actually like grow that into something
broad it really requires like discussion
and brainstorming and like other voices
and other other thoughts very difficult
to sit there and a computer screen and
just laugh by yourself did you get
makeup yeah it was terrible really don't
want makeup does it be a little bit
there's a more than a little bit I
survived makeup okay minty interesting
[Music]
we wanted to give Google the experience
of what it's like shooting a video with
us everything from conceptualizing to
writing to being on set filming we're
showcasing a behind the scenes look into
what it's like shooting a video with us
without actually shooting a corridor
video I'm so happy that we picked this
outfit because you showed up this
morning and the wardrober said love what
you have on
yeah feel like we walked into it with
sense irony but now I'm starting to
actually embody this new style that's a
really nice sweatshirt I'm kind of
jealous to be honest my socks off thank
you yes Jake pick them up dance you
don't like these pants I like the shoes
why don't you like the pants
yeah probably pants yeah no I do like
the shoes thanks I picked him I'm proud
of you man corporate millennial are you
why because this couldn't have worked
out better it turns out you hit the nail
on the head in a way that was unforeseen
to both of us
I think that that means that it's like
I'm just trying to look really stylish
guys are fantastic and heavy camera
right now yeah it's this heavy sweater
where Paul Bunyan jr. in the front his
father's killer who is the is the evil
like lumberjack you're the you're the
anvil corporate logger forest and this
is Paul Bunyan jr. not Bunyan jr. Paul
Bunyan senior Paul Bunyan is my son yeah
I'm actually Paul Bunyan this is like a
retelling of the Paul Bunyan story so
improvise so Paul and then Paul Bunyan
normal you're Paul Bunyan your problem
your junior you're my son a grandson
because you've are senior that means
junior the second the third Paul Bunyan
to the foot the hurt what have you done
to offend me so much that I'm trying to
cast more
you remember in any acting course
there's who you are and then there's
your objective you know who you are
yeah publi engineer ok what's your
objective I need to tell you about
what's the impending doom that's about
to hit ok and my objective is that I
think that you're an alien and not
actually my grandson
no you think he's a treat you want to
see the coil Sam you can't tell us I'm
soaking this up right now I feel like
that was the cleanest one we've done so
far with a blunt end of it yeah he
doesn't want to kill me yeah I miss
grandpa oh yeah it's for the camera
I don't really know what I'm doing here
I watched this video about what to do if
you fall out of a plane without a
parachute or if you fall out of a plane
with a parachute and everything goes
wrong first stuff staying in there long
as possible is the first priority you go
like a flying squirrel creates surface
areas to slow yourself down it's the
only incremental you want to look for
like some boggy stuff some fields and
some trees and bushes you don't want to
hit water because the surface tension of
when you fall into water really fast you
should know this about water but if you
fall from water too fast the surface
tension either breaks your leg because
you're hitting it too hard or what
happens you go you break through the
water the water expands and then
contracts and hits here really hard that
can knock you out cold girl that's
really dangerous yeah yeah no it's like
the first thing that can hurt you is the
obviously is surface tension just
destroying a tree yeah that's the only
logical so now remember we're here
freeze all right let's see that tree
right there
I mean comparing it she goes right
through you won't you know it it might
and and see that the things we're
talking about 99% chance of death or
100% chances so let's see so you can't
find a tree
you don't sniffing uh what you want to
do is when you hit you want to like send
yourself into a role right away when
you're in around the idea is that right
is rough hit the ground you want to take
your momentum and you want to do that
you change the angle in which you're
striking it down it's not just like this
it's a and and it takes a lot of that
velocity and puts that into a spin what
takes the velocity away from the impact
let's say you've survived any of those
situations you've hit maybe hit the tree
maybe hit the ground you're probably
really up probably broken some
bones if you're still alive and the
thing you want to know is that your head
you're probably gonna be in shock and if
you have yourself on
[Music]